it was
so good it was and it was me just me and
tom the whole time tom would write the
idea he'd give it to me i'd do it were
you guys just buddies before you were in
comedy yeah yeah did you know each other
before you were both in comedy no no i
met him we were both working with uh
another comic uh jaymore and
okay yeah and jay walked in and
tom was in the green room at the improv
and florida state was on the
tv and jay didn't know tom and i didn't
know tom and we walked in and i was like
hey you're watching florida state and
he's like i grew up in florida i go i
grew up in florida because florida
state's my team i said that's my team
and he went yeah and he said i have a
hundred dollars on this and jay walked
in and he goes you have 100 on a game
and you're a host and jay goes yeah and
he goes you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
walked out and i go hey welcome to the
tour
and then just that that camaraderie of
that ball busting between me him and jay
at the time tom and i got really really
close
and uh and then and then you know and
then yeah we're like yeah so you were
both florida state not the university of
florida that's the uh florida yeah
that's the rival yeah i went to florida
state tom didn't go to florida state he
went to some small college in north
carolina who are the gators that's
university of florida right did you do
greater growth i did the gator growl i
think i was at that were you i think i
was why would you be at that that
because you still went to those like
especially i think you did it in like 80
i did it like in the early maybe 90
maybe 90. yeah but but uh it was the
biggest audience i've ever played is uh
you know 80 000 80 000 people people in
the stadium and it was tradition to have
a comic
every year do it did you ever well you
wouldn't do it right so i think i did
this sounds crazy but i think i might
have done
pow-wow i did i did pow-wow which is i i
did that too but that was indoor
that was indoor it's it's less like 10
000 inside an arena inside an arena so i
did pow-wow this year i think i did
powwow i'm not certain if i did or not
but i performed at homecoming at florida
state but i don't think it was
set up as powwow but i saw bobcat
goldthwait do powwow i saw adam sandler
do powwow and and and i i want to say i
saw you because you you probably saw me
you probably saw me at powwow i probably
saw you at powwow yeah but we would go
down to gator growl because they had big
comics come on right i want to say like
uh carrot top did it yep um cosby really
it was 80
000 it was such now i look back and i go
it's crazy i i mean i i can't imagine
either how did you do that how do you
perform in front of 80 000 people that
that's
um it was it wasn't fun but it's great
to say that you did it yeah you know
it's not really fun because and also
it's really hard to to work the crowd
you you and rose c
i watched i watched uh
i watched bobcat try to work the crowd
and and they just started yelling play
free bird
[Laughter]
when did the whole thing with you with
no shirt start uh
it started
i guess maybe like
maybe 10
15 or 12 years maybe ago i don't know
really
what happened but that's your signature
what happened was i would get on the
road and i would thursday would be a
bummer of a show for me because i would
think thursday night you got a whole
weekend ahead of you you and
and especially if your numbers were low
you'd be like oh there's gonna be a long
week
and i would find that if i didn't do
something to change my personality about
that i would all i would almost bring
that energy with me on stage so i
started ripping my shirt off and killing
a beer on thursday ripping my shirt and
then i throw it back on and then i just
started ripping my shirt off on every
show when i get on stage rip it off kill
a beer and make me giggle i'd play uh
ram jam black betty yeah it would make
me giggle and i'd go
this is uh this is this is what it
should be and then one night i was at
the i was at the columbus funny bone and
i ripped my shirt off i killed a beer
and um
and i forgot to put it back on and i
just got into something interactive and
then someone in the back i went oh i
haven't put my shirt on i want to put
her on there's this woman in the back
she goes keep it off and so i kept it
off sexy i got off stage and someone i
really respected a comedian i really
respected said to me that's really
impressive you just did an hour with no
shirt he's like imagine
how those jokes would work if you had a
shirt on like that was distracting and
then i said oh what i'll do cause i
heard that george carlin before special
would grow a beard because it was harder
to be funnier with a beard than right
before the show especially shave it off
because and then it was all of a sudden
it was like swimming in in like in like
uh overalls you know right and so i was
like what i'll do is i'll do stand up on
the road with my shirt off and then when
i go to a special and i put on a suit or
a collared shirt i'm going to be a
monster because i've been doing it
shirtless all this time and then i went
to go do my showtime special and i
realized oh i'm not really comfortable
in my shirt
yeah i was like i'm really uncomfortable
in a shirt and showtime told me they
were like hey i'm just giving you a
heads up
we're doing two shows you should do one
of the shirts i think that you're gonna
want to do one in a shirt you're giving
people a reason to change a channel like
when you rip your shirt off there's a
big swath of america that's going to be
like oh that's not what i'm interested
in and they're going to change channel
everybody loves tits and it doesn't
matter whose they are i wish you could
tell that to those people at showtime
that year because i had the lowest rated
special they had ever done no one
watched it it was it was like they give
you a list of all their specials and
that was at the bottom but then i what
happened is i
i took that machine clip i took a bunch
of clips on that special and i posted
them on facebook and the machine story
went viral and because i was shirtless
all of a sudden that was like a
marketing thing right and so like i
remember
very shortly after that i was at the
airport uh the american airlines
admirals club and a woman sat down next
to me and she goes hey
hey
i know you and i was like i don't think
you do she where did you grow up i went
to high school with you right and i was
like i went to all boys catholic high
school she was like no i know i know you
how do i know you the bartender's
watching this
then she just goes
oh i didn't recognize you with your
shirt on and the bartender lit up like
what she's like you're burnt and i was
like yes i am she goes oh my god i love
you i i and i was like oh yeah and now
it's like i remember when it started
really popping and like i did my i did
my
hey big boy no secret time with my shirt
off and it did really well and sugar
called me laughing hysterically and he
was like
you are going to have to be shirtless
until you're [ __ ] 70. we're gonna do
something at the mark twain awards and
you're gonna be [ __ ] 70 years old and
you're going to go hey guys and rip your
shirt off at 70. because you got to be
shirtless for the rest of your [ __ ]
life
[Music]
bye